I had an experience earlier this summer
which I probably shouldn't tell but I
will that is an example of how it gets
weird we had we a friend of mine moved
to London and left me his library for
unspecified amounts of time to keep a
very bizarre library mostly platonic
stuff a lot of magic a lot of that sort
of thing and so we build a book loft for
it and our house is wedge-shaped and so
this book loss is way up at the top of
the house and I was alone in the house
and I took seven dried grams and I was
sitting there and it was just beginning
to come on I was in the show what you
know thing phase and it was beginning to
show what it knew and there was this
disrupted area of space in front of me
where it was like rotating and I was
looking into it and talking it up and I
was actually speaking at first I was
just speaking in my mind then I would
began speaking aloud and I was saying
you are beautiful thing you are
beautiful and suddenly there things
changed and it became very cold and
meaning the temperature fell suddenly
and the dog next door who never howls
howled and the cat which was down below
me and was up in this loft looking down
at our bed the cat was on the bed the
cat flared out and made this really
weird noise and I just you know I
stopped what I was doing and projected
my mind into this situation and at that
moment I heard this sound which was like
and then something settled on to the
roof sufficient to make the six by
fourteen inch beam
creak in just went and I was floored and
I just I just sat for a minute and I was
not frightened in fact my emotion was
hard to get back to but I wasn't
frightened but just at that moment this
thing was really coming on and really
visually peculiar and it seemed like the
two things were independent the trip was
getting stronger and stronger but a
10-ton something had landed on a roof
beam of my house so I just sat with it
for about 30 seconds and then this
thought or voice came and it was this
thing has come because of something I'm
doing and that means that I can get rid
of it so I just turned like this up
toward the roof and projected this
thought very strongly which was begone I
am in conversation with an elder and
this thing went and there was a long
pause ten seconds or so and then
whatever it was it lifted off the roof
and went away and what was weird about
this was I had never I had never ever
used in my own mind this phrase an elder
to describe the mushroom it was like
just came out of me
and the whole episode seemed real weird
to me and I just let it ride but that's
an instance where you know there is this
let's call it synchronicity so that we
don't have to believe that it's very
tactical the dog my rook
there is the synchronicity for some
reason they're chose to be a fluttering
sound and the being chose to creep now
doubtless this has to do with
temperature and the cooling of they
denied but you know it was a thing to go
through
[Music]
you